mir zugeschaltet ist jetzt der grünen
politiker cem özdemir
guten abend herr özdemir haben auch sie
das okay wir befinden uns in einem in
einer öffnungs diskussion sorry ich kann
die kanzlerin verstehen das spricht ja
auch ein bisschen die
naturwissenschaftlerin das merkt man
ihren vorsichtigen worten mein eindruck
ist dass es da so ein bisschen ein
schaulaufen gibt es das ist ja nicht
ohne grund auch zufälligerweise
übereinstimmt mit denen die sich um den
cdu vorsitzende damit um die
kanzlerkandidatur bei der union bewerben
das ist aber jetzt nicht der augenblick
dafür sollen jetzt geht es wirklich
darum dass wir verändern müssen mit
aller gewalt das ist ein zweiter starter
gibt man stelle sich mal vor sie als
journalistin wie sie uns zu recht als
politiker löchern würden wenn wir jetzt
auf einmal alle zügel locker lassen so
tun als ob wir quasi über den berg sind
und dann gibt es da mal ein rückfall das
wäre katastrophal für die wirtschaft
katastrophal für die gesellschaft ist
wer aber auch katastrophal für das
ansehen der liberalen demokratie wasser
auf die mühlen von allen die sagen die
demokratie bringt sowieso nicht von der
reise schon richtig dass die kanzlerin
uns zur vorsicht mahnt unser ziel muss
es sein dass wir die die am meisten
bedroht sind das sind die älteren das
sind diejenigen die zur risikogruppe
gehören dass wir die schützen nach wie
vor sterben menschen das wird da gerade
leichtfertig vergessen
auch ich würde mir nix sehen die ja es
rauszugehen auch ich will wieder draußen
sein ich will mich mit freunden treffen
ich will hingehen wo immer ich möchte
also wie jeder normale mensch aber
nochmal diese krise muss man ernst
nehmen und ich habe die bilder jetzt
gesehen am wochenende
ich habe schon so ein bisschen das
gefühl dass die diskussion auch dazu
beiträgt dass die disziplin nachlässt
nichts wäre gefährlicher was würden sie
machen wenn sie kanzler werden würden
sie versuchen die einschränkungen ein
bisschen zu lockern oder würden sie auch
für die bundeskanzlerin
davor warnen dass man da zu weit geht
wie lockern ihr lockern ihr schrittweise
das auch richtig natürlich müssen wir
schauen dass mehr geschäfte aufmachen
natürlich müssen wir schauen dass gerade
die klassen die jetzt vom abschluss
stehen wenn das die auch wie
in die schule gehen können das ist doch
völlig klar gleichzeitig müssen denen
helfen die in besonderer weise betroffen
sind ich mache mir große sorgen um
diejenigen dem saisongeschäft tätig sind
neben city hotels nehmen sie die
gastronomie für die fällt ja eine ganze
saison flacht die werden erst in der
nächsten saison wieder schwarze zahlen
schreiben aber das geld werden sie nicht
zurückholen
da werden wir helfen müssen flexibel
helfen müssen wir werden unsere
wirtschaft helfen müssen wieder auf die
beine zu kommen aber bitte schritt für
schritt um jetzt kein wettlauf in der
ministerpräsidenten oder andere
politiker aus der opposition namentlich
der fdp ich verstehe es dass jetzt
gerade die opposition und teile der
opposition sie ein bisschen sorgen
machen um ihre umfragen aber das ist
bitte schön die falsche krise dafür die
populismus zu betreiben es geht um
menschenleben
es geht um unsere volkswirtschaft es
geht um deutschland es geht um europa es
geht um eine schreckliche pandemie das
ist nicht der augenblick für populismus
für billige schlagzeilen vernunft ist
jetzt das gebot der stunde bitte vieler
bürger können trotzdem nicht verstehen
man darf draußen keinen kaffee trinken
man darf aber kleine läden betreten die
kinder sollen teilweise in die schule
aber in die kita nicht können sie das
verstehen
schauen sie ich habe selber zwei kinder
und ihr habt die probleme wie schwierig
es ist wenn ich hier telefon mit ihnen
bin oder der video konferenz mit ihnen
bin ständig schalten habe diese woche
seine sitzungswoche wird als geheilte
auch in den sitzungen teilnehmen
die kinder sind gleichzeitig zu hause
und die sollen nicht den ganzen tag mit
dem mobiltelefon verbringen sie kennen
der die probleme die eltern sondern
sollen sinnvolles tun also wünsche ich
mir nichts sehnlicher als dass meine
kinder endlich wieder die schule kommt
aber gleichzeitig wünsche ich mir auch
dass meine kinder da ich eine mutter hat
die 1933 geboren wurde
wenn ich dann möglicherweise was
mitschleppen und meine mutter an stecken
also muss beides ihnen vernünftiges
gleichgewicht gesetzt werden
schrittweise vorgehen ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir zum beispiel den
ländern stärker folgen die jetzt
vorangegangen sind mit einer masken
pflicht darüber müssen wir reden in
deutschland wenn wir wollen dass wir in
die läden gehen wenn wir wollen dass wir
den öffentlichen verkehr nutzen dann
brauchen wir eine maske pflicht darüber
muss geredet werden es muss darüber
geredet werden
dass wir masken verfügbar haben in der
breite da kann man glaube ich noch
manches besser machen da ist das
krisenmanagement der bundesregierung
sagen wir mal vorsichtig formuliert
suboptimal gewesen befallen auch noch
andere dinge ein
ich denke die verfügbarkeit von tests
wir brauchen dringend massenhaftes damit
wir auch die zahl derer feststellen die
die krankheit schon durchgemacht haben
die geheilt sind weil die können
natürlich dennoch stärker eingesetzt
werden also da geht noch deutlich mehr
wie das was die bundesregierung macht
die opposition kritisiert das muss das
kritisieren aber bitteschön
verantwortungsvoll
ich habe das vorher schon mal gesagt was
hätten wir in deutschland für
diskussionen wenn wir nochmal zweiten
shut down wollen den darf es auf keinen
fall geben
ob das aber auch anzunehmen dass wir da
gar nicht drumherum kommen die kanzlerin
sagte ja auch heute wir müssen jetzt
schauen was in den nächsten zwei wochen
passiert wie sich die lockerungen
auswirken und hat ja durchaus auch in
aussicht gestellt dass eben genau das
passieren kann
sollten die zahlen wieder exponentiell
nach oben gehen also wir müssen die
diskussionen konzentrieren auf die wo
jetzt gerade druck am meisten ist das
sind die die kinder haben sie haben es
angesprochen denken sie an
alleinerziehende über jetzt auch
menschen mit behinderung über die
spricht gerade gar niemand besondere
problemfälle menschen die in beengten
wohnverhältnissen sind wo es zu hause
vielleicht auch probleme gibt aussehen
schief hängt die sozialämter die
kinderschutz kennt diese fälle da müssen
wir ganz besonders glaube ich rein
aber wie sagt nochmals mich haben die
bilder auch ein bisschen verstört die
ich da jetzt wieder gesehen haben dass
die disziplin droht nachzulassen
da müssen wir jetzt dringend dran und
wie in der politik das schließt die
opposition ausdrücklich mit ein sind ein
besonderer weise gefordert verantwortung
für das ganze zu übernehmen wir sind
nicht nur jetzt gerade verantwortlich
für unsere partei wir sind nicht nur
verantwortlich gegenüber dem ein oder
anderen bürger mit ihr zurecht druck auf
uns macht sondern wir sind für die
gesamte gesellschaft verantwortlich
die gesamte gesellschaft geht gerade
durch eine schwierige phase und ich
verstehe ist dass da die einzelnen
gerade sehr laut sind aber man muss es
vom ende her denken
deutschland ist und bleibt ja auch was
die regeln betrifft einen flickenteppich
in berlin beispielsweise haben heute die
ersten schüler ihre abi prüfungen
geschrieben finden sie das
unter diesen bedingungen richtig also
ich verstehe es natürlich dass gerade
die abiturienten ganz besonders unter
druck stehen weil die drohnen ganzes
jahr zu verlieren da braucht man
lösungen das kann ich gut verstehen was
ich nicht verstehen kann ist wie in nrw
dass man die diskussion macht dass die
schule jetzt schon wieder ganz öffnet
ich sehe gar nicht wie das geschehen
soll
schauen sie ich habe lange zeit in
meinem leben bildungspolitik gemacht ich
war dafür dass auf der hauptschule der
realschule
ich habe ja die fachhochschulreife
gemacht als ich habe sehr viele
schulformen in deutschland durchwandert
und ich kann ihnen sagen das ist
mitnichten so dass es überall warmes
wasser gibt es mitnichten so dass
überall die klos im besten zustand sind
es mitnichten so dass du über eine seife
findest also sollte man mal bitte schön
dafür wird die schule in dem zustand
sind dass wir die kinder da auch guten
gewissens hinschicken können
und wenn man gerade dabei sind dann
sollte man bitteschön auch dafür dass
die digitalisierung vorankommen wir
merken doch jetzt gerade in der krise in
der desaströsen zustand in unserem land
die digitalisierung ist es ja zum teil
auf entwicklungshilfe niveau was den
ausbau von breitband internet angeht da
muss sich der ein oder andere
csu-minister der letzten zehn jahre auch
mal kritische fragen gefallen lassen
bayern da ja gerade sehr laut ist diese
an waren die letzten zehn jahre dafür
verantwortlich das muss besser werden
nicht merkt es ja mit meinen kindern
wenn ich das vergleiche mit freunden in
finnland da ist digitalisierung
selbstverständlichkeit die verlieren
nicht wirklich zeit wir verlieren gerade
zeit weil wir die zeit nicht so nutzen
können in allen schulen wie es notwendig
wäre
immer stand heute dem stand der heutigen
technik eigentlich machen könnte wenn
das know-how da wäre wenn die technik
dafür da wäre ja findet ihr im haus
versetzen ohne internet schauen da
wirklich im wahrsten sinne des wortes in
die röhre eine letzte frage an sieht
markus söder regte an als politiker auf
teile ihres gehalts verzichten sein wie
finden sie diese idee machen sie damit
ich finde es richtig übrigens nicht nur
politiker ich denke da auch an manche
fußballprofis und andere manche gehen ja
voran zu tun sich da etwas schwer damit
das bin ich richtig deshalb hat sich
meine fraktion ja auch gemeinsam mit den
anderen demokratischen fraktionen dafür
eingesetzt dass die nächste
diätenerhöhung die jetzt anstehen würde
ausfällt das wäre jetzt glaube ich der
jetzigen
unverständlich viele in unserem lande
leiden in ganz besonderer weise und auch
wir politiker müssen uns da solidarisch
beteiligen indem wir jetzt auf die
diätenerhöhung verzichten die fußballer
angebundene schläger soll ja jetzt
wieder staaten dürfen im mai freuen sie
sich darauf ein großer fußballfan ich
drücke mein vfb stuttgart die daumen
dass er wieder aufsteigt und wird
natürlich auch gern die saison zu ende
spielen um zu sehen dass wir das auch
tatsächlich geschafft haben andererseits
verstehe ich natürlich dass viele bürger
sagen jetzt reden wir die ständig über
fußball und die anderen denken sie an
erzieher und andere bleiben außen vor
insofern ich finde die diskussion muss
man führen über geisterspiel habe jetzt
sage ich mal als ehemalige handball tor
hat den ich immer der ich in meiner
jugend war
bitteschön ein bisschen derzeit auch
über die anderen sportarten mal reden
wir reden die ganze zeit über fußball
aber es gibt schon auch viele in der
gesellschaft die anderen sportarten
nachgehen auch da müssen wir uns
gedanken machen ich will daher nicht
eine situation haben wo wir die ganzen
vereine die wir sonst in der breite
haben dass die sich das nicht leisten
können das habe ich mich zum beispiel
auch an der kampagne beteiligt dass ich
mal die trikotnummer spende da gibt es
ja ganz tolle aktion von aktion fair
play und anderen kann dann nur empfehlen
sich dringend zu beteiligen
auch das gehört wenn sie so wollen so
infrastruktur deutschlands dass wir eine
tolle vereinsstruktur haben übrigens
nicht nur profi vereine sind natürlich
auch die ganzen amateure